the local agent says I've been under
investigation for some time their role
is to run down drug people and far as I
can make out there they're not getting
anywhere 88 year-old Bob Wallace and his
85 year old girlfriend Margery Ottenberg
have been a couple for a very long time
Bob and I've been together for G but 20
years 35 years 35 years teen time flies
when you're having fun Bob is a Stanford
educated engineer and Marjorie is a
former chemist and they fell in love
climbing to the tops of the highest
peaks in the world
look I climbed Kilimanjaro at age 72 I
climbed into later oh yeah
and these are walk ups combining all
their interests they created a water
disinfected for backpackers like
themselves called polar pure out of
their garage in Saratoga California and
for people in their 80s it was a great
way to keep busy especially for Bob
who's a bit of a tinkerer you know for
an old guy with nothing else to do this
is something to keep a vacuum pipe it's
a simple product just water mixed with
iodine crystals and backpackers have
come to rely on it for decades first we
know no one has ever gotten sick using
it and it's probably avoided a lot of
sickness it's a useful product so that
we feel very pleased about its
widespread use until one day Bob and
Marge got some shocking news about polar
pure the DEA says it is also profoundly
helpful to meth makers in 2007 the DEA
tightened regulation of iodine because
they were afraid it was being used to
cook methamphetamine the new regulation
classified iodine as a controlled
substance and named polar pure in
particular as a product that was of
concern to the DEA and that is what
really got us involved in this
particular problem
since the key ingredient in their
product was now a controlled substance
things got tricky for Bob and Marge
the DEA told them sure you can continue
to operate your business but you must
pay a $1,200 regulatory fee register
with the state and feds report any
suspicious activity and keep track of
each and every person that buys a bottle
of polar pure of course we can't count
the people who are using it the overhead
alone would be too much to pass other
customers so that's why I didn't bother
with their room because I would be out
of business if if we follow their
regulation it was the same for camping
stores and online outlets who stock
polar pure they pulled it from their
shelves rather than having to deal with
the headache of new regulations
effectively killing Bob and Marge's
business any time you're dealing with it
government it's ahead well not
necessarily but usually here's what the
state had to say about Bob he's legit
business man he that products been on
the market for years it looks like he's
an unfortunate byproduct of the meth
craze the DEA wasn't a sunny spokeswoman
told a local paper that Bob was
collateral damage you can probably
imagine how frustrating this whole
process was so when the state asks Bob
to install a security system in his
garage sent them a picture of his dog
buddy security agent and because Bob
didn't follow their new rules
the DEA used their power to cut him off
completely threatening a supplier of
iodine not to sell the Bob the local
agent said that I've been under
investigation for some time I was kind
of flattered the whole thing is so
ludicrous absolutely is that ludicrous
it's sad it's well it's funny and it's
sad stupid they're being put out of
business they're totally being put out
of business Stephen downing is a former
LAPD deputy chief and a member of Law
Enforcement Against Prohibition I
believe that the DEA is the most
out-of-control arm of the federal
government today they've been given so
much authority and have so little
oversight Downey says that authority
comes from the very powerful controlled
substances act within the Controlled
Substances Act the DEA is given
authority to regulate chemicals as they
come up as they see the need to reg
these chemicals according to the new
regulations set forth in the 2007
Federal Register the de A's new approach
to iodine was meant to make it easier to
bust meth labs to make it easy for
federal enforcement people to so-called
do their job and make their quotas and
and have their show and tells they pass
these regulations that impact innocent
people but in so doing they harm so many
more people that have other uses for
those those drugs and those chemicals
their role is to run down drug people
and far as I can make out they they're
yeah they're not getting anywhere they
are creating situations that allow them
to say see how well we're doing in this
war on drugs we're shutting down meth
labs and we're taking these terrible
distributors and we're shutting them
down and we've stopped the flow of this
and stop the flow of that but they never
talk in terms of the metric that's most
important how much has method used
declined and how much has meth
trafficking declined and the answer is
it hasn't it's true the Justice
Department's own national drug threat
assessment for 2011 said that the
availability of methamphetamine was
increasing in every region of the
country and the rates of abuse were
increasing as well
there were meth heads before polar pure
went on the market and there will be
meth heads anyway the worst part of all
of this is that Bob and Marge aren't in
a position to fight back in any
meaningful way Bob Wallace is an easy
target because he doesn't have the funds
to hire a lawyer and go to court and
challenge this kind of unconstitutional
behavior so he becomes a victim and they
count on that they absolutely count on
it he's collateral damage and she smiles
and she laughs and that's the truth for
many victims caught up in the drug war
no matter what you say or do the drug
war just has more power than you my
career has been making stuff designing
stuff building stuff solving problems
what do lawyers bureaucrats and
politicians do they make the problem
it's a matter of providing something
that people need and all of a sudden we
can't and refuel for the people who need
it and can't get it give me something to
do over that's true keep him out of my
hair
[Music]
[Music]